is it all good for secret hideout and
Paramount or is there some disharmony
and are we about to get a big
announcement regarding the future of
Star Trek welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so I have to do a quick video on this
because the information's just come in
and I'm not 100 certain what to believe
on this so I've got to tell you this is
firmly in the room a category
but it does make sense what I'm being
told so let me just say straight out
what I'm being told is that tomorrow the
big announcement on April 5th will be
that section 31 a mini series of section
31 is going to be announced now this
kind of makes sense because we were
expecting big announcements tomorrow
um the April 5th date is quite a big one
in Star Trek isn't it's kind of a new
one
um and we got some announcements last
week regarding Starfleet Academy that we
weren't really expecting they seemed to
be a little bit out of the blue
they would only make sense if there is a
bigger announcement potentially that
Michelle yo is even going to star in
this mini-series
that they want to you know have that its
own day for so they wanted their own day
for this so they announced staff at the
Academy a week earlier
um because you know that deserved its
own day as well
so that would make sense and it is
logical from that point of view and from
what Alex kurtzman has said him to
complete constantly saying actually that
he's very excited about section 31 still
now I've said that it was a big doubt
for section 31 and a lot of sources that
I speak to in around Hollywood said it
was a big doubt not impossible but a big
doubt so it does feel like something has
changed for excusement and secret
hideout now another thing that I said a
couple of weeks ago was that the future
Star Trek was Terry mattalis now this
was based on actually a source that I
speak to who doesn't work for Paramount
but this is did some work basically for
pyramids as part of a marketing
um assessment and they basically went in
and they did from a marketing point of
view
um how
um how effective Star Trek was for a
cost impact ratio and they did this
loads of maths and things while they
were in that meeting and they were asked
repeatedly about Terry matalis now I
took that to mean that the future of
Star Trek was terminals because why
would they be asking so that's my bad I
may be two and two plus five there I
apologize
um but the fact that Paramount was still
asking about terminalis then makes us
wonder what is going on and would Terry
metallis potentially get section 31.
well the rumor is no this is going to be
a mini series
kurtzman is going to direct and showrun
and that it really is his baby
now why wouldn't Taylor's be involved
because he is such a popular figure
within Star Trek at the moment
well apparently Paramount would be very
keen they've been very excited and very
interested by the reception of season
three apparently though secret hideout
is not the king and they for some reason
seem to be blocking the move photo
metallis
now I've heard from a couple of people
that are very anti-kirtsmen this is
because kurtzman is jealous of the
reception that metallist has got Force
um the season three I would like to hope
that's not true and I really hope that's
not true
um but I have heard that kurtzman isn't
the most trusted person in the world
when it comes to the Paramount
Executives so who knows
further that though if that is true and
terminality is being pushed to one side
by secret hideout rather than Paramount
it would maybe explain why they're
getting these projects and why Terror
metallis isn't going to get the Star
Trek Legacy that actually a lot of TNG
fans would like we want the you know
Titan to carry on its Mission and we'd
love to follow that
so we'll have to wait and see but to
find out whether this rumor is true not
when I have to wait very long because
Wednesday is tomorrow so let's see what
happens
I'd love you guys though to get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you're
thinking there is a big kurtzmann hate
group out there now I don't follow that
I don't like that that exists really and
there's a really big split between the
Star Trek fanbase there seems to be
people that love new track and seem to
be people that hate new track and the
people that hate it blame kurtzman
I'd love to know what you guys think
about that and is it really helpful for
the long-term future of at the end of
the day a franchise we all love
I'd love you guys also to get into
comments to tell me what you think about
this rumor that it is going to be a
section 31 mini series that gets
announced tomorrow is that something
you're excited about
because I suspect that will also be in
the discovery time frame
so hmm
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
as always you can go and have a look in
the description there's loads of links
for loads of safe track related stuff
I've managed to do this video in one
take I don't think I have to edit it at
all I've never done that before amazing
as always guys stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]